>>NEW CNN RTING THIS
RNOMRE
WORKIN A LEGALNT FDENT LESS THA
FOERS.MIGUEL MARQUEZ HASN TALKTM
ANIA, TO SEE
WH TN AN
IS LIVE NOW
WHAT ARE TLLING YOU, ?
>> Reporter: GOOD MORNING,
E UP HE EXPECTING
NS ACRTHE
BOULD BE00T
STUDENT LOANORGIVE BER
T EXACTLY Y STUDENDEBTND
T FORGIVENESS.
>> WELCOME TO THS
MARK Reporter: TAR
REAL DEAL.
>>A POLKA.
>> Reporter: FARMERS FROM THE
AREA SELLIHAEY GROW.
KIND O ARE YOU
>> WE'RE HAVING A FAIRSON.
FOR 50 YEARS.JIM HAS FARMED HERE
LIKE MANY REPUBLICANS HE SAYS IF
ONE BORROWS MONEY, THEY SHOULD
IT BACK.
>> IT'S A LOAN, IT'S A LOAN.
>> RIGHT.
TAKE A LOAN TO BUY
TO PAY ITACK.THEY'RE TAKI A AN
EDUCATION, THEY SHOULD.
♪♪ Reporter: BUT SOMREPUBLICANS
>> IT SES THE COUNT MOVING TOW
>> Reporter: PHI VOTED FOR
TRUMP TWICE.
DOESN'T HE DIRECTION OF
UNTRY, BUT ON STUDENT
LOANS --
>> IE A LOSTUDENANOF FOR MY ILD
Rr: HE SAYS HOT
AGAINST STUDENLOORGIVEWE W HOR D
QUALIFY.
>> THERE HASOME CHANGE
AN WHAT
AN
>>-OLD TOM, A UBLICAN ANER
BANKER SAYS DEBTS SHOULDE
REPAID, BUT VIEWS STUDENT DEDIFH
COLLEGE, THEY HAVE STUNTLOANS.
I'D LIKE TO E IT.
IT HELPS THEM, YOU
E  ALLHIS
FREE MONEY, SOMEBODY IS G TOE P.
>> Reporter: A SENTIMENT
SOH WORKINCLAS
FROM THE EARLY 2000sT POLLARD TP
INDITE TYPICALLY
NT OWHITED VOTERS,CRATS ABOUT
THAT SPLIT FOR OBAMA ANDP. IT,
IN  IN BETTETHAN CLINTON
>> WE ARE STHEAVEN.WE ARE ALMOS.
RE IN OU>> BIG A P OURCONOMY AR
LOANS?
I  IT'S A HUGE PART OF MY OMY, L
TO HOPEFULLYEN CAROF.
>> T 2018, HE WORKS PHARMACYY HB
$36,000 INEB STARTING  DOWN THE
ROAD IS SOMETHINTHAT I WOULD
BE VERY INTERE I
I MEAN, MYURRENT DEBT
SITUATION HAS MADE THAT
FACTOR FOR JT EVERYONE. E SADDL
>> Reporter: THIS CA
OWNER RS
NG AND STARTEDTUDENT LOA.
TAKING ON
>>THAT CON YOU GO TO TEMPLE, TH
TO TAKE ON.
WE CAN HY BUT THIS IHOHOW MUCH M
THOSE WERE VERY LARGE PARTS OF
>> Reporter: FOR MANY HERE THE
SPIRALING COST OF COLLEGE TWEIG.
>> I HAVE KIDS, SOME OF THEM
HAVE STUDENT LOANS AOT
WEALTHY AND YOU CAD PAY
AND NEVER TOUCH THE PRINCIPAL.N
STUDENT DEBT TOUCHING JUSTUNTRY
EVERYONE'S LIFE.
AND, LOOK, NO ONE ON THET
T OKTHAT THE STUDENT LOAN ENESST
OTHETHE MIDTERMSY DIDN'T
THIT WAS GOINGH
OF A DIFFERENCE.
INTA VCOULD MAKE ALL THEFFERENA
HAVETU DEBT, ARE THEY PP THIS?S
DIDN'TAV
EGE, TIDS,Y'RE SEEING THEM
LE WITH IT AND IT AFFE
THEM.EYME L O FORGIVENESSS
WELL.
ML,N SHA JOURNALISMEE SO MANY
GOING THERE,
VIBE OF THE NATION.
ING TOR
OPK THIS HAS
THEIR
I'TTLE SURPRISED BY THAT
HEARING IF THIISFOR YOU,
YOU LIKE IT, ANDF IT NOT,
TAKE A THIS THRI
BUT YO SAYING THERE AROFEOE S A
IT MAYAKE CE
T IT JUST MIGH DIFFERENCE.THAT
WHA GRANENT
AND HAVE WHO VE DEBT AND CLEARL
PARTIES ARE FIGHTI VS
HEREKNOW
WA A FEW DAYS AGO, HE IS A BEENA
WORKIN VERY HA W, THESE WHIT
BLY SHOCK T
OF THESE VOTERS EV